christine is in florida this morning yes
Christine Oh Howard tell you how much I
am enjoying the app and my favorite part
besides the puppet show is the big
blockade in front of Fred I pee myself
every time I watch the video because
that's all I focus on yes Freddie's
completely blocked out I I have it so I
never see Fred you built a wall I built
a wall like Trump and he keeps spread
out it's a wall of it only keeps from
one person I call you I don't mind Fred
being in here as long as ever have to
look at those faces he made let me tell
you something wide that that exists and
for those of you who have the app and
have noticed that Fred is completely
blocked out of my point of view it's
always been that way I don't look at
Robin during the show I hardly ever do
and I hardly look at Fred and the reason
for that is when I do the show I like to
just hear them as you hear them and
that's the truth
I you know if I look over and see what
Fred's doing I get totally fascinated by
what he's up to
same with Robin but more so with Fred
actually because like right Robin when
you look at Fred you can like these
faces being made and I'm like that guy
at the Trump rally yes exactly like that
guy and so I built a wall now by the way
I don't know if you know this about our
studio if I ever want to see Fred and
I've never done this I have a button I
can hit I can lower his screen yeah not
done it once I've not done it once to
see him I've disconnected should I do it
there's that button work I think the
batteries are dead
all right you ready this is for your app
you can watch this tonight on your TV
you are now going to see Fred there we
go I hope this works
[Music]
I'll look at it oh that's funny should
play the theme from 2001 to space no
he's not very left he's so funny
hilarious oh there he is yeah he's gonna
be there hi Fred hello can I put it come
out like between those TV sets the
computer screen there he is clamp let me
see you now let me see you Knight there
he is
there's Fred but he is he's distracted
right you know back in the day he used
to sit behind you
yeah and I could see him and it's
distracting and I would be fascinated
with the chewing of the pen yeah and yes
text to the moving of the head and the
expression that don't match what's going
on right I know I know it all I love the
guy I love him but the eating yes
or how about when the eyes rolled back
into the head when he's trying to think
of something right you know when I met
Fred I met him in Hartford in 1970 no I
was about 1981 or something or 80 80
problem and we didn't have this
technology this screen that goes up and
down and I got to tell you was hard it
was very difficult but I'm gonna put it
back up Fred with your permission or
without your permission
there we go Robin look that's the
optimum where the screen is coming up
again it moves very slowly yeah it
reminds me of when they have to close
the roof at a tennis match right you
have to wait there it goes before the
action starts again no more Fred I
blocked the walk and this date this is
what Trump wants to do with the
immigrants you know I just put up a wall
if only it were that easy all right
fred is now hidden from my view in the
audience's view and I doubt I'll ever
take that screen town only up
[Music]